all of marks lines in this video are
actual lyrics to the song bad blood by
Taylor Swift haha you see that no I was
too busy punching this old lady and
taking her money ah all right what are
you guys doing back so soon
now we got problems and I don't think we
can solve them what's the matter the
bank job go wrong well actually it was
going smoothly and then accidentally
killed a guy with this you made a really
deep cut now we got bad blood I
apologized
you say sorry just for show I'm sure you
guys can work it out all that matters is
we got the money did you have to do this
I was thinking that you could be trusted
it was an accident I was running with
marks favourite scissors did you have to
ruin what was shiny now it's all rusted
we'll buy some new scissors mark yeah
with all that money we got right it's
not my fault
Oh did you have to hit me where I'm weak
baby I couldn't breathe why'd you have
to hit him there you know that's his
weak spot and rub it in so deep you know
I don't think of you that way
salt in the wound like you're laughing
right at me so about that money I don't
know what you think we had oh it's so
sad to think about the good times you
and I where am week you are ruining my
credibility on the streets man so what
do we do now all the cops are out
looking for us so don't think it's in
the past it happened five minutes ago
all these things will catch up to you so
I'm assuming you got the money in your
coat right no sorry you say sorry just
for show so what are we doing to fix
this
well if Mark wasn't rushing me I could
have slapped the guy from dying
band-aids don't fix bullet holes bullet
holes I thought you killed him with
scissors actually he was screaming so I
tried to shut him up with this gun and
he died time will heal all wounds time
but this won't mark we talked about this
you know it used to be mad love I think
you're thinking of someone else mark cuz
baby now we got bad blood you know I
didn't give you that take a look at what
you've done
whoa whoa
you